carlos on for the fourth time he's 3-0
he's just been brilliant
you look at those numbers they just jump
out at you what really jumps out at you
is that right-hand hitters don't do
anything with them .087
most amazing for a guy that usually
neutralizes the left-handers
two and two is a called strike three
pinpoint
to the top outer corner and one gone
coming from the sun to the shadows
grossman didn't want to offer it a high
fastball but it was there tripp gibson
on the call that's the four seamer
upstairs on the mound for carlos rodon
this year
as this one two is chopped to third and
monkatta
for out number two
breaking ball for strike three that was
a different shape of a slider
high slider worked wonders look at casey
mix record so far one and two
we want to see the casey that threw down
and uh
beat the astros the splitter was very
good that day
this one's sent to right
that's where victor reyes is
he's
very energetic he goes he's got a little
bit of pop there too sure does but
jacoby jones has got as he stumbles
backwards into the wall
now he had a little sun for you right
there
he's looking back he's got it right in
the corner of his eye
and uh jacoby's usually really good at
knowing where he is on the on the wall
that time he was a little shorter than
he thought but did hold on to it
so far this season the 3-1
right back to casey mods 10 pitches
gets casey mize through the first and
congratulations to michael with a very
cool story that he can tell his friends
for a long time as tim gets nearly
knocked into next tuesday by a line
drive from scope
and one away this is a line drive rocket
but fortunately tim right there
rotella was hit pretty hard as his
momentum carries him into left field
like tim was going to end that back
pedal in 2023.
hit the ball really hard overall this
year
not there
fastball top side third strikeout for
carlos so far it's all both pitchers
against all the hitters
this is some high heat it's in the
strike zone it's at 96. he started this
game with a 91 mile an hour fastball
then threw it 92
1-2
struck him out
as the ball was traveling to the plate
carlos was walking off the mount
they're not even going to flinch at it
they're looking in a certain area if
they get it they're going to put it
there every play by cabrera and they'll
turn the double play
[Applause]
right on the second that was nice
that aggressive slide
with a nice tag
and an accurate throw too very good
it looks like it might be a change up
anyway doesn't get a swing
here he does strike three that was a
change up and one gone so that's why he
pointed to himself
and then he struck him out with a high
heater
six strikeouts eight batters for carlos
rodon
wave and a miss another changeup seven
in nine batters and collins is now at
third
for leori garcia one away here's the 2-2
oh that's a big strikeout for casey mize
2-2 to anderson oh he did he got him
back-to-back strikeouts with a man at
third base
and that strike three
eighth strikeout for carlos rodon
to 12 batters
a runner in scoring position with two
outs
scope absolutely smoked the ball his
first time up
that's a bullet down the left field line
and that's a fair ball into the corner
grossman trots home jonathan scope has
himself an rbi double here in the fourth
and the tigers have a one nothing lead
change up he gets it up
and hits a rocket
[Applause]
and that stolen base by robbie grossman
he scores easily
it's hard to piece hits together on a
pitcher this good
opens it out at some point there it is
check swing he did go ah we'll have to
leave that in the bands counselor but
it's good to see him off to a good start
good start for casey mize as he strikes
out adam eaton here in the fourth
[Applause]
struck him out reyes gets rid of the bat
collins gets rid of reyes
and the tenth strikeout for carlos rodon
2-2
oh he vaporizes another he's got 11
strikeouts that ties his career best
with the bases loaded nobody out well
hamilton's going to hit for himself
on the ground to first cabrera bobbles
it and the socks get a run out of the
deal it's an error on cabrera and the
game's tied at one but for all intents
and purposes that is an error that gets
a run off yeah it's going to be an easy
force out at the plate instead the game
is tied
and cabrera knows he's coming home with
this you're not going to turn the double
play that's for sure but he then puts
the tag on
and the infield's still forced to stay
in so that is
a run batted in so here's laorie garcia
who will
slice this ball to center
and the sox will take the lead
vaughn and collins score it's three to
one
one two that one's 97. he's got a new
career high that is his 12th strikeout
rodon's two oh a little pop up behind
the mound and near second it's fielded
on a hop by garcia he'll throw to first
and a nice job to work out of the sixth
inning the tigers leave a man
another three two and he takes strike
three good pitch by casey mize fooled
him for his fifth strikeout of the day
here's the one two man he struck him out
nice way to end the six for casey mize
struck him out slider from liam
hendricks
13th strikeout for sox pitching
elevated left side
tim's on the run he makes a strong call
and makes the catch for route number two
two and two
slider check swing roller jose's got it
to hendrix and the sox have won game one
of the double-header on another fine
performance from carlos rodon and a
rally for the offense in the fifth